hey what's happening thanks for tuning
in to another episode of left to be
talking is Monday July 20th and this
episode is brought to you by the rock
and roll machine makers Earthquaker
devices yeah Earthquaker devices you
play guitar bass keyboards your maniac
you need some stompboxes you want to
sound badass on stage you want to light
the candles of rock get yourself an
earthquake or device it's a stomp box
it's a foot pedal it's a rock and roll
box a machine you know what I'm talking
about
[ __ ] you put your guitar and stomp on it
it goes till 11 as the famous spinal tap
would say this amp goes to 11 earthquake
your device's find them at earthquake er
devices calm follow them on Twitter
Instagram get yourself a nice stompbox
my good friend won all it already uses
it you know him from Mars Volta and that
guy does some serious bass licks on your
grave
get yourself an earthquake er device
and here we are podcast is late today of
course because I was out in Toronto all
weekend
what a [ __ ] weekend man Wow
thank you everybody that came out to the
rock and roll circus
we had the epic show on Saturday night
everything that went wrong went wrong
and everything that went right went
right the AC went out it was the hottest
day in Toronto the humidity was on a
hundred swamp-ass or as I call it puddle
of mud that's some puddle of mud going
but wow what a [ __ ] weekend I can't
believe it I say it over and over but
man everyone that's listening to the
podcast is coming out [ __ ] is happening
getting some butts in the seats and it's
all because of you guys spreading the
word and you know grass roots Metallica
style like I said keep telling your
friends about let there be talk and boom
it's happening man
what a great weekend eight [ __ ] loads a
barbecue at the aft bar oh I can't
believe I made it home red bad and I got
[ __ ] crazy ate about 20 gallons of
candy and then about 20 gallons of
[ __ ] barbecue and about 7,000 [ __ ]
ice coffees and you got a nice healthy
diet a Dell razor diet I'm out of my
mind it's [ __ ] hot in LA today too
it's humid it was raining here all
weekend while I was gone [ __ ] crazy I
just say the summers are now winter and
the winters are now summer you could
call it all you want global warning or
warning global warning warning like it's
Queens Reich global warning but global
global warming whatever
I think [ __ ] just the prayer you know
the calendars it's changing you know
that's all winners in the summer now
just like I said a couple days ago
bombing on stage is the new killing man
anyway love you guys
today got a great guest mr. J Moore is
my guest today and we recorded this last
month while we were on the road in Las
Vegas Nevada and we talked about some
crazy [ __ ] how would you plan your
funeral yeah I never talked about that
I'm afraid of death it's the only thing
I'm afraid of I'm not afraid of dying or
I wouldn't ride a motorcycle but I am
afraid of
[ __ ] off cancer [ __ ] like that death
that you can't [ __ ] slow death life
is probably a slow death right but I
mean you know what I mean anyway how
would you plot your own funeral
weird weird [ __ ] topic we talked
about that we talked about rock and roll
we talked about what else with films
movies everything any time Jay Morris
and I sit down and talk it gets
interesting I love talking to him we go
all over the board and he's just [ __ ]
fantastic check it out before we get any
further let's see just saw train wreck
about an hour ago
nothing another reason this podcast is
late and Wow
go see that it is funny Amy Schumer
everywhere everywhere lately and
well-deserved man she is so [ __ ]
funny great actors in this movie I loved
it
all kinds of my friends are in it it's
awesome to see uh you know it's great I
hope you guys already seen it you know I
think it was number one this weekend I'm
not even sure but I think it was and
well deserved I remember seeing Amy
Schumer about three years ago I didn't
know who she is or who she was I was at
the meltdown her and Jeselnik came in
they were gonna run their roast when
people roast people for the Comedy
Central Roast for about a month you'll
see him around at clubs running the
material and she came in and she
destroyed and I was like who the [ __ ] is
that
she is a gangster she is outlaw I loved
it just spewing out radical [ __ ] great
woman hats off to her man go see it and
congrats on all your success Amy
Shermer I know you listen to this
podcast I even know who I am
alright one last thing I flew home from
Toronto and I was watching movies and
boom they had Giants on I hadn't seen it
in probably 20 years James Dean giant
and you forget as the years go by I
forget how [ __ ] great James Dean was
and he's like one of my top favorite
actors of all time but I just [ __ ]
forget you know out of sight out of mind
three movies and then he goes which is
the [ __ ] bummer you know but man
watch giant sit down and don't [ __ ]
text her and it turn your phone off and
watch this [ __ ] epic saga it is
amazing I mean everyone in this film
crushes and my good buddy the one I love
the most Dennis Hopper is right in there
like I always say Dennis Hopper worked
with all the [ __ ] best James Dean
Marlon Brando what else David Lynch he
directed colors I mean he's done at all
he worked with John Wayne I mean there's
no one cooler than [ __ ] James Dean
and you know Dennis Hopper did two
movies with him
so that makes Dennis Hopper cooler in my
book math I'm [ __ ] kooky today whoa I
don't know why I'm so out of my mind I'm
jacked up still from all that candy and
meat I ate this weekend I'm back on the
marination tour we're rolling into
boulder colorado on the 24th and we'll
be in Denver on the 25th get tickets
marination me and Marc Maron I'm coming
in with him what a [ __ ] great week
and that's going to be and then of
course Dell razors in death squads San
Jose improv July 30th come on down get
tickets right away Bay Area I guess
that's about it probably I'm out of my
mind
[ __ ] pekin ready to get this episode
to you enjoy your week light the candles
of Rock and keep those reviews going wow
I got a bunch of new reviews
that was great on iTunes thank God it
was sitting there stale for a minute
so keep the reviews gone you want to
donate to the podcast email me at Dean
delray at yahoo.com it really does help
believe it or not fake oh thank you
there's a little burp for a nasty delray
see ya hey what's happening here we are
another episode we'll have to be talk
live from Las Vegas at the South Point
casino just finish the show with James
you guys cool let me see you lighters
like because I do that bit on stage of
you know my rules about yeah singers
don't tell me where to vote for don't
tell me what charity I should be
involved with yeah don't tell me what
town I'm in and then I go I actually
take that one back I'm guilty of
freaking out over that one you're in Las
Vegas and the stones like having
strangers yeah yeah bother you like what
are your ground rules like when bands
get first of all go out relatively on
time if doors open at 8:00 I should have
be there at 11:30 going where are they
yeah yeah well I do a bit where I say
rocks not dangerous anymore and a singer
singer said make sure you recycle
recycle yeah isn't it amazing like how
much comedy I think we talked about this
less than one left every talk was like I
don't think comics realize like 80% of
their act has already happened to them
and you just gotta like sit tight yeah
and eventually like that thought bubbles
gonna go into your head and you're gonna
go oh yeah that's right that lead singer
said don't forget the recycle yeah I
should have yelled something back at him
I did I said I want to recycle this take
it back you suck it's true though you
that I think the way you get great as a
comedian is you start to realize oh [ __ ]
I can just tell these real stories in my
I like the feels killer you know that
kind of stuff is starting to happen now
you don't I mean but you know we're in
Vegas and it's so funny I saw
Springsteen here 99 and you know when I
was a little kid nobody any anecdotes
about your life I'm here I in love Bruce
I want to hear Candy's room I love Bruce
but the problem now is he is a just a
little too much Americana on stage you
know where he's like the president of
rock'n'roll the band who fell the ground
Samantha to the cannon on the Trump
match like Pentecostal preacher yeah
Anna Doggett I saw it when I saw him at
Staples I'd done like Wow yeah you see
him like a year later and he's still
doing it you're like oh and then he's
it's like when when you think a comic is
ad-libbing the whole say yeah yeah yeah
like Charlie flashed around once we saw
at the Laugh Factory in your like wow
yeah this guy made up his entire [ __ ]
said he's radical and you see him like
the next week and it's the exact same
and you're like oh yeah well which is
the talent unto itself to make it look
like an eye condition I'm not knocking
Bruce I love but if you watch like 75
Bruce suddenly season yeah that Eric New
Jersey and YouTube yet like we need you
and you're watching him and you're gone
like this guy is living the [ __ ] out of
this right he still is now like
unbelievable performer his body's
incredible his voice is incredible
he plays amazing but I don't think he's
living the [ __ ] out of it somebody asked
him how come he doesn't write more songs
about himself
yeah and he said I do gigs I go home
when would I write about like I don't
think he's really know I'm saying on
stage no he goes 100 I can to not [ __ ]
yet I mean so great but I like my
favorite performers are dark and
mysterious you know like if you go see
Chris Robinson he's high as [ __ ] and
he's not killing like you know he's just
up there like far out man
you know let's see how you do
let's see where we can take this you
know whatever and you're just going like
whoa what do we paid you thought
actually worship the devil yeah
absolutely
he played Led Zeppelin two backwards
yeah yeah you were like hail Satan or
whatever yeah yeah and then it's like so
absurd like Jimmy Page just age like
like he's now just this erudite
gray-haired man I love him notch song
remains the same it's like good versus
evil like Robert Plant swearing why
Jimmy's wearing black their Knights
they're [ __ ] jousting [ __ ] yeah like
you know one time my wife and I were
watching it was a Shatner doing Rocket
Man and like whatever show he was doing
it Hawks it
yeah cigarette bucket man yeah and I'm
like I'm trying to formulate what a
douche bag is I want to say it the right
way right because my wife's the first
person to ever make me want to speak
concisely and correctly and as I'm
thinking of it she goes she says [ __ ]
confident yeah I was like wow like I
could not have thought of anything that
cool like this guy Shatner can't sing
yep beak sings yep and he's sitting on a
stage with a cigarette and he's acting
out [ __ ] rocket man yeah you can't
take your eyes off I love him pretty
confident his version of common people
destroy Jarvis cockers common people I
just read some [ __ ] on him if you read
it he's Canadian Shatner yeah that's
[ __ ] up is what I read about him which
is unbelievable when Star Trek comes out
it's only on like three seasons and then
it's gone and and basically the people
on that show are gone
and somehow he keeps pushing he's living
in his car after Star Trek like I'm
[ __ ] don't you know cuz it's really
yeah I'm talking like five years later
can't get anything then he gets like TJ
Hooker you know the major in Xiamen
right yeah Heather Locklear yeah and
then the show yeah right and then he
gets another show and then he gets that
long commercial run and and then they do
the movie
and legal yeah Boston Legal it's better
and and and I think he's like they said
83 or something right now it looks great
I know right I just read this because he
was saying he got a lot of flack for not
going to Spock's funeral and he was like
look man five months before I knew he
was done I booked this Red Cross thing
and I didn't want to you know cancel on
the Red Cross you know I don't you guys
yeah it's Fox oh that's your guy yeah
yeah I know cross you do it the next
time I'm dead serious
yeah yeah I guess so right you're going
my man died do you understand you and I
have known each other
1/10 the amount of time yeah Leonard
Nimoy and [ __ ] Shatner an entire
lifetime they spend together yeah and
like we've never done like a get like a
show yeah and show of that magnitude
yeah just like live long and prosper and
to boldly go where no man yeah you know
I got this gig man the improv the night
yeah you know I can make a funeral dude
on Terry on my website by the way I am
if I can plug a couple things I mean are
gonna be at Comedy Works in August
that's in Denver all my dates six seven
eight of August say one six seven eight
of August oh I did that last time I was
on it made you crazy oh yeah uh-huh
August 6th R is the 7th and August 8th
we're at Comedy Works Denver yep I go to
gym we're not calm for my dates I really
did upgrade my whole site like there's
new content pretty much every day yeah
and it looks good the dates like cash
comes out on Monday Tuesday there's this
guy called glove and boots I put up
feeds of that and then there's this
thing that we put up on Jay Mohr calm
called this happened which is weird
shits I think I'm gonna go as far as I
can with Pro Wrestling fails like Hulk
Hogan pulling his own head of out of a
box
yeah like acting's like freaked out and
he just see the audience staring like
this is the dumbest [ __ ] I've ever seen
but also tonight as you said
live in Las Vegas yeah that's some South
Pointe casino and how'd you like the
show I thought it was great it's a weird
room because but let me quickly if you
go to my site the blue hey man t-shirts
that are 50 bucks you go hey why is this
shirt [ __ ] 50 bucks how long was i
with those dudes after the show yeah man
you get to go backstage it's great it's
a great thing you know yeah it's a great
thing by the blue hey man shirts and if
you want to listen to more stories
there's a more stories app I encourage
you to do so now you got to go to
Leonard Nimoy's for home bro yeah
everybody has to speak at the funeral
what's that have you ever been asked to
speak at a funeral now I got a rule no
funerals no weddings I don't go I know
guy I went to one funeral go to a little
wedding well I went to a funeral and it
was my buddy and I'd never been to one
you know so I walk I wasn't prepared for
hell is gonna [ __ ] with me and I walk up
to the coffin and he's there and he's
got makeup on and and he's dead and it
[ __ ] tore me up for a long time I was
like I'm not doing that again
I just if they pass away I deal with it
on my own but to see it what if somebody
asked you like brah I need you at my
[ __ ] sister's funeral I can't do this
I need you to it can't well if it's
somebody I don't know and a guy needs
something a buddy yeah yeah I would go
with him for that I'm talking about when
it's a dude that I know or a person that
I know really well and I go it's [ __ ]
like I said I went once and I was like
oh this doesn't work for me you know so
you've been to like one funeral in your
whole life yeah yeah because uh you know
that's the reason I became a Catholic
was that my my wife's aunt Janet's
funeral yeah the story no aunt Janet
dies right they live in st. Louis and
the uncle Sonny calls my wife's uncle
Sonny and he asked me to be one of his
wife's pallbearers yeah and I was like
of course I'm doing the math he's got
enough sons to cover the load right
yeah so a couple sons got boxed out big
family right I'm like wow and my wife
said and Sonny said to me he goes the
happiest my wife ever was after for the
last like decade of her life - she was
so sick was that you're in NICs wedding
well I'd be honored if you and I'm like
first of all like you being honored then
I'm gonna help lower your bride into the
grave like it's all weird to me yeah
yeah but it is like it's almost like
being knighted in the most morbid way
possible somebody's asking you yeah
Terry their dead wife you know - that
whole yeah so I said yes right so
because Sonny called me so the whole
time Dean I'm in this church I always
wanted a military funeral yeah in the
military 21 gun salute
yeah I always wanted one of those yeah
but I'm not in the military then I
played movies roles where I was like a
cop and there's a cop funeral you get 21
gun salute there - or fireman funerals
yeah but I ain't gonna get that [ __ ]
yeah well you can't man you can get one
I'm gonna Catholic you just pay some
people to come down [ __ ] man well so how
about if you just played the song for
those about the rocker you got the
cannons at the end as them over and that
is my funeral right
it's just going down as the cannons are
going off everybody hears this you know
as the casket goes down yeah yeah as
it's going down it's just like pong
actually I've already plotted out mine I
want to be cremated because I think
there's too many bodies in the ground
taking up prime land right now yeah you
know I mean like with another golf
course or yeah with that that area where
all the celebrities are buried off
Barham there what's a cone as far as
long that could be some of the best pads
going so I want to be cremated and then
I want my buddies to hike I'm gonna make
him work hike Half Dome I'm from I was
born in Yosemite
just throw them off half them the ashes
half dawn yeah and you salmon a yosemite
half down half no it's the biggest piece
of you know granite I'm gonna take so
many rashes I'm just gonna [ __ ] flush
him down the toilet
take a big log what was the movie where
they snored at him was that Boogie
Nights or something there's Keith
Richards there's his friends to snore
them so go let me quick okay so I go to
this journal I'm carrying is not yes
yeah I carried it what the funeral I'm
at is Catholic very st. Louis Catholic
and they got like incense and chants and
as the first funeral ever went to where
people went to the funeral that did not
know the deceased they went because they
were Catholic and they went to the same
parish well that's like a cop to know
where all the cops come because one of
their brothers went down right all right
that's like went down they came out and
I'm like looking around and it was just
pageantry and I already knew like the
same things to say and they said it
peace be with you and like 400 people go
and peace be on to you I was like woah
yeah I want to know the words this scary
stuff and I realized no wasn't scary was
I'm [ __ ] cool oh really so I said I
could do a Catholic funeral so I start
thinking in my head like I want my
funeral to be cool like this yeah so I
told my wife remember sunny called me
called called the keyword called yeah so
I start tripping out like it was just
this real weird religious experience I
had not spiritual like strippers I'm
just kind of spiritual it was religious
yeah Pacific to Catholicism so my wife
said when you go to a Catholic Church
and audit it just sit in the back and
see how you dig it just pick a mass and
go just see if it's for you right yeah I
go I go cuz I feel like I'm being called
upon Sonny called me and I feel like I'm
maybe being called upon for something
bigger I'm sitting in the back of a
church and the one senior walks out to
do the mass and that's not normal my
seniors don't really do it they're kind
of like the mob boss right yeah usually
the lieutenant's running mass remember
what's the key word call yeah call
called you guy walks out nine AMS at st.
Monica's in San
and he just goes for he just looks
around doesn't say good morning and goes
we are a called
upon people as if I just said to him why
do I feel like I mean called upon yeah
because we are like why would you start
a mess that way like that was weird
right yeah yeah I'll go home I tell my
wife she was what's amazing she was what
Catholic Church did you choose
I went st. Monica's she's just get the
[ __ ] out of here yeah I got why she goes
that's where I was baptized Wow like
this is crazy
yeah I converted so there is that was it
cuz a lot of atheists get on me like
book an Invisible Man and this guy go no
bro my church is cool there's a gay and
lesbian Stations of the Cross
you see maria shriver over there going
O'Brien's there and like 40 homeless
dudes holding like [ __ ] pit bulls
really so when I owned in there yeah Tom
Brady got married there where our lease
funeral was there far oh yeah Chris
Farley yeah man I was gonna go for the
joke but I don't know any other famous
Farley's like green Lorne green yeah so
yet my funeral if I had to play a
[ __ ] tearaway funeral I don't know I
think you got it nailed that those about
the rock and the casket being lowered to
the party cool does it go down
incremental watch goes down like yeah 10
inches yep
and you time it out 21 actually I think
what's even cooler is it's one of my
favorite ac/dc songs everything about
it's a good opening guitar I got
rewinding that's our target it's eight
seconds I just go back and everyone it's
a saga Denton and the way Malcolm comes
in
yeah and then the lyrics it's like what
you are about to receive we are the
dealers
we give you everything you need those
rappers got the ride away you know so
[ __ ] that's great so I think the caskets
up and as the guitar starts going it's
moving down slow you know by the time
they get to the canons it's in the
ground I think you put a cannon in the
casket yeah the lid off yeah and you
[ __ ] come out for the people always
say like Tupac faked his death Morrison
what would be great is if you actually
faked your death and then you can hear
people talking about it I'm sorry yeah
there you go
not the rush song yeah actually yeah
look the kid goes to his own spoon
that's a funny Robert Duvall did it in
the movie get low get well oh really
so whatever funeral he plays all old ask
me a giant a spirit yeah and she was
have a funeral and he just sits in the
back and wants to know what everybody
[ __ ] says about him okay he calls it
getting LA won't get a little time to
get low get low good movie I never seen
that it's really he should how he didn't
get nominated is beyond me because you
got and I'm gonna front of the judge
yeah which was okay
yeah but like well that's always the
yeah it's the maker like oops like yeah
he no sensible woman yeah you're gonna
wait a minute you missed a lot Meryl
Streep for [ __ ] Mamma Mia like yeah
we nominate Sony for Mamma Mia yeah
Meryl Streep I don't think I would go to
the Oscars any yeah 18 nominations you
gave me two they asked my ass yeah see
you later
no one is better than Meryl Streep any
given year and she's beautiful yeah
Jersey girl Madison New Jersey deer
hunter [ __ ] her and walk and come on
most beautiful people on earth in that
movie everybody thinks walk-ins like
this big goofy joke now Christopher
Walken in like Annie Hall yeah and deer
hunter is one of the most
ethereal beauties right dude deer hunter
when walking they're doing the Russian
route
that it's one of the most brutal scenes
it's mama no more no that seemed to me
it's is the biggest coup cou P in
cinematic history because people don't
realize is there's a guy old and a
[ __ ] boom mic yeah probably
sixteen people at that table yeah right
now full full film crew
he's got holding a bounce card from
light yep in the narrow does that
[ __ ] scream into the load click yeah
[ __ ] I don't know how they get to that
level but I don't I never [ __ ] sniffed
it so I don't know I I just memorize my
[ __ ] [ __ ] right wait for the pause and
then talk sometimes I forget when I'm
watching a movie I watched these
classics over and over and over and over
and you completely this is what makes
it's so incredible you forget that it's
a movie they made that something like
you and I you've done some mood
you did great movies I did some shitty
movies but you went somewhere so they
went to like Cambodia they they fly
there as actors they learn their lines
they get out into the swamp and then
they become completely different people
and for the rest of our lives we see it
and don't eat when I look at those
I never go that's Walken and Pacino
there I mean uh too narrow there I never
say that ever you know I just look at it
and go well I just think it's two guys
in this vietnam war of course you know I
know but I'm just saying at that level
it's crazy yeah there it is other level
and when you look at movies like
Apocalypse Now
you know there's [ __ ] that like they
like Martin Sheen and a heart attack
yeah well they're Fords Fishburne was
like 12
it's my favorite 13 favorite film Harvey
Keitel gets cast as the lead they fire
him two weeks in yeah they already had
posters made this would this
this is the one thing in Hollywood
that'll never leave my brain where is
the footage of Keitel it wasn't two
weeks is four weeks four weeks yeah so
four weeks they're in a [ __ ] PT
Cruiser going upriver yeah like I am
like the black guy to the chief of the
vote yeah love them yeah I'm the chief
you know and he's getting in that
argument like oh like what did they film
yeah yeah I heard it was the hotel schwa
to exterminate with extreme prejudice
yeah I heard they filmed the hotel scene
you know look that's Francis Ford
Coppola and zoetrope he ain't gonna
throw that [ __ ] away I know
[ __ ] Daly it's it's a month of
filming I collect like stuff from movies
I love we are gonna go upriver and get
Colonel Kurtz frankly sir I don't see a
method never get out of the goddamn boat
you know you gotta do you gotta have a
guy let you dove in Keitel's voice on
all of the Xin Xin scenes gonna river it
would it would explode on YouTube I'll
do yeah that would be cool project ID
Charlie Sheen on my podcast in his house
yeah he's good he's got to get you know
what happened I got two guests from
being on The Tonight Show as the second
guest yeah I was like their guy and I
told them like I did 21 tonight shows
right around like the 21 yeah I got [ __ ]
I got a post-it note my most prized I
have no possessions I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah no luggage racks on a hearse you
can't the only thing you take with you
is what you give away yeah love kindness
sympathy compassion so like one time
jerseys they used to collect when I was
in my 20s yeah I don't give a [ __ ] Yeah
right
I got a pat tillman Jersey that I'm not
gonna toss cuz it's a [ __ ] pat
tillman Jersey yeah but it's not like
cuz it's mine it's just mmm number forty
guy died in [ __ ] I got shot friendly
fire it's [ __ ] up but like all them
Jersey days to clack all autographed
baseballs and [ __ ] I got so many
footballs and storage on about I don't
care at all
once Tracy fist came up to me there on
The Tonight Show set during a commercial
with a pink post-it note I said to her
how many times have I been on before the
show yeah she goes I'll find out for you
I'll ask I forget the other lady's name
so take in between commercial and she
comes up to me with a pink post-it note
it was the other producer lady a post-it
this got the last pink posed
Yeah right this is Jay's twenty first
appearance in pen it's all it says Wow
that's framed in my house and they get
but in the guest room where nobody knows
where yeah yeah yeah but that little
[ __ ] post-it note right just so
casual yeah of my life altering a thing
that happened yeah twenty-one times but
it this is Jay's 21st appearance and a
little pink post-it note in a shadow box
that's a cool thing to have it the hot
so cause people go what's that and then
you got a great story like I but I
wanted to be there Buddy Hackett so I'll
make this real quick my 11th appearance
I said look I want to be your buddy
hackett like how Carson had Buddy
Hackett yeah like anytime somebody falls
out I'm here yeah and that's what
happened Wow
and I booked two guests on more stories
like Charlie Sheen I said are you going
to do my podcast and like two weeks
later I just call him and he goes can
come by tomorrow man just come by man
just come by tomorrow man
so what maybe think of this is in the
middle of a podcast he's all over the
place he's like super 8 wasn't [ __ ]
[ __ ] up for anything he's just yeah
he's a nutty guy yeah yep any guys you
want to see something amazing you see my
dad's helmet from Apocalypse Now
whoa yeah I do bro he takes out whoa
captain Willard helmet from the movie
yeah what's it on the table
I could feel seething [ __ ] negativity
coming at me and waves off that helmet
yeah bro it was nuts Wow Wow like
seething [ __ ] bad mojo coming out of
that dump Wow race Wow
and I am making that [ __ ] up yeah put
that on the table and it was like whoa
whoa-kay
yeah cool my buddy went to a mmm the
Coppola
Winery recently and i guess you can go
into this room where they have all the
archives and there there's like the
[ __ ] cameras that you know hopper
warren there's the [ __ ] stick with
the [ __ ] heads on it me know where
else I tell dailies yeah they're round
but here's what I I love collecting
stuff of [ __ ] that I think is iconic and
I saw a original movie poster for it
with Keitel's name on it really yeah it
was on eBay and it was like seven
thousand dollars like yeah there's
probably only saw your motorcycle yeah
probably like ten you know or but they
had made some posters like you know like
all right this is gonna be the poster
weather shoot in the film you know like
right away they start making posters cuz
you know that can't became a two year
shoot but they probably thought it was
gonna be six weeks you know they got
trapped
yeah they got trapped them though storm
came and wiped out this set
yeah heart attack if your star for the
Marcoses military yeah yeah so they
would take off and they go where they go
and they go there was fighting a war
right now yeah they gotta go Neela
filming yeah half your [ __ ] actors
yeah I like later yeah and also I heard
that they used real bodies from morgues
from that war in the scene there those
are like real bodies hanging OH
so tune is good great yeah um lost best
picture to dance with wolves no
Goodfellas lost danced with Wolves oh
yeah and Raging Bull lost to ordinary
people put under people's actually extra
fee Rahsaan how Raging Bull lost to
ordinary people what other people is
extraordinary though but but it should
have won you oh yeah I mean me I'm all
in I always get into this of movies that
didn't win or when people don't win I
just talked to Todd Barry about how like
Sean Penn did not win for dead man
walking that was the year Nicholas Cage
won firmly we I catch on Penn's Ark was
just very oh no he was incredible
oh I went at the end spoiler [ __ ] you
sport as far as [ __ ] it's 30 years kids
quiet like that's kinda just what you're
waiting for the whole time so it's like
it's just kind of like a pleasure but
and you got away now and I have to get
it I don't know I was like Nicolas Cage
being that [ __ ] naughty felt too
cartoony to me then Nicolas Cage thing I
partied my head off I know people that
party the head off they're not like that
you know I know lots people of Nicolas
Cage impressions I don't see enough of
them you go on YouTube yeah and you can
see like a montage of guys doing awesome
Nicolas Cage impression really yeah I
love him in that what was that movie
that weird one man glad you liked my
movie what was that one um oh [ __ ] oh
man take a weird movie I love with
Pacino and that's insomnia oh yeah Robin
Williams yeah man he should have been
nominated for that when Robin Williams
is serial killer
Robin Williams man they're up all [ __ ]
like for a week cuz the Sun never goes
down up in that part of Alaska yeah
and Pacino was like seeing tracers
[ __ ] up fridge and Robin Williams
knows it starts playing them yeah
they mean the ferry and Robin Williams
because I'm not who you think I am and
Pacino just goes he could barely keep
sigh I think you're a piece of [ __ ] you
think you're special because you cut her
[ __ ] nails and painting you're about
as interesting to me as a pipe is to a
[ __ ] on my job what's Nicolas Cage
movie it's the what is it inception or
whatever what's that movie called no I
just did all this cover for you just you
could think of your movie I know I'm
just trying to remember what it was it's
it's that one where they go around in
time and [ __ ]
I don't know that Oh what is it I know
nikka time is great with its inception
isn't it or no that's that lyric are you
it's [ __ ] everyone is listening to your
podcast yelling the [ __ ] out right yeah
they are there it's a great fellow old
it's probably from the 90s you don't
even know a decade it is you dizzy prick
it's so great like I don't know the name
of it but it might be from this era you
will you know you know it's amazing
and see people wore hats sometimes my
brain works fantastic and other times it
gets [ __ ] better not be talking about
face off
no no [ __ ] now leaving Las Vegas okay
all right it's after that it's
incredible yeah it was I'm VP yeah
riveting [ __ ] podcasting we got
calling here this is good no it's not
got some stories no it's not looking
[ __ ] he's 6 feet tall he's sweet little
name is Kim yeah he's a Coppola Nicholas
Kim Coppola
he's a Capricorn you know his nickname
is no Nick Nick [ __ ] says that on the
Internet no tails above Sophia Coppola
you do as a director no no as sometimes
elevation videos so yes she was in that
she's so great she she enjoyed no she
just did it now she's beautiful though
in that era
like Godfather 3 all right I have a
different opinion and I will say this
yes I got brother 3 in the theater and
when she got shot the whole place
applauded oh well yeah so no well no it
was terrible
10 and he was great in supposed to be
when I write only make bad lieutenant I
was like you gotta be [ __ ] me
yeah yeah and I watched it port O'Call
oh yeah the New Orleans wine is great
yeah it was great oh yeah good job that
man people didn't see that they slept on
it you know that thing is [ __ ] crisp
grindhouse ghostrider Wicker Man World
Trade Center weatherman lord of war
national treasure lord of war was great
adaptation was amazing
somebody just told me I should say
that's it that's the one you travel
around in time you wanted [ __ ] the
Kaufman twins yeah that's it that
thing's caller he not when he lets go
for that I that movie is Fanta
dick how good he troubles I can't think
it's in the ninth about a writer yeah I
couldn't remember what it was it's like
it's like Jim Carrey in that spotless
mind my eternal sunshine that film is so
good and it's a son oh my god what's
your favorite film of all time
yeah can you do it yeah it's either
Goodfellas I mean it's got to be
something that's like so perfect that I
watch it it's better yeah Goodfellas is
underrated yeah I don't like it well
think it's watch ya know like Goodfellas
Raging Bull was my favorite movies yeah
fine but there's times where I can
fast-forward oh and in Goodfellas
there's not a frame I can miss Wow every
time I watch Goodfellas there's
something in it that I go oh he knows
he's a [ __ ] rat when the mom goes
Henry what's wrong yeah you don't talk
that she's gonna look on his face like I
gotta watch out for this you know why I
mean it's it's cool and it's good movie
Goodfellas my favorite movie man really
over Godfather 1 & 2 um it's so poorly
lit oh people go home he's a genius
cinematographer in The Boathouse like no
I can't see I you got [ __ ] two actors
in a room I don't see either of them I
love the Lakers lit up like a [ __ ]
operating room behind them in the snow
who's going for it like no no director
is gonna go I can't see my actors this
is great I love I can't see how Pacino I
love the look of it it's all burnt amber
you broke my heart frame oh yeah oh yeah
Fredo I'm looking at IMDB of Dean del
Rey oh yeah all right actor yeah for
this yeah delivery guy on merit oh yeah
that's great project Tennessee noise
matters yeah
noise matters just came out while doing
in the search for the
allies Bennett video short play dead
play dad the longshots
Ice Cube he'll ride you played a pet
Tarantino ape [ __ ] you should
you're very castable yeah yeah I'll tell
you one thing Dean doll right you're one
of very few comics I love watching every
time you get out there did you watch my
set tonight you make me laugh what the
[ __ ] you live on the inside there's a
guy from the table of Republicans a
little bit to your love he just had his
balls out as surely go you guys driving
from Utah yeah like none of it's like
revolutionary yeah I'm saying yeah but
the way you say it you you know there's
the old expression like breaking the
fourth wall yeah but like when you break
it you kind of come through like [ __ ]
kool-aid like coming through the brick
wall oh yeah you're not like like you'll
even we're at the Irvine in front of
months yeah you go like this chick you
know she [ __ ] I would never dream of
saying I got the reputation of being
like a [ __ ] weirdo yeah yeah look at
this chick you know she [ __ ] yeah
sometimes it works sometimes you guys
afraid hey what are you afraid of that
are you afraid that she's gonna be
Maddie huh are you afraid she's gonna be
mad or again like when you tell anybody
I don't want anybody to ever I mean
anybody yeah there's 2,000 people in an
audience I want all 2,000 people saying
not good not great that was like the
single greatest comedy show I've ever
seen in my life
right they see 100 stand-up shows yeah I
want that to be their [ __ ] van Halen
at Oakland Coliseum yeah it's like yeah
but I did see this so everything pails
yeah so I wouldn't want to take role I
roll the dice with the material right
and I go out on a couple weird ledges
yeah
yeah and if they're down they come with
you like the bit my wife wrote on this
so what I'm afraid of is I don't want
anybody like [ __ ] him yeah I couldn't
have that in the room yeah that's not
our job I hear you my job you know it's
a very specific service industry yeah
but you know I've never seen anybody
turn on if you ever have any audience
member go like [ __ ] you know yeah it's
always somebody that's trying to be on
the spot now I'm gonna put you on the
spot now that you've got my attention
yeah that's what you're doing now let's
see yeah I always just want like my wife
wrote um like my last special the
Showtime special that she wrote and
there's a whole bit about irony yeah how
I hate it I don't have it nothing so bad
that it's good nothing so stupid that
it's cool yeah and I tried that like
three times and it [ __ ] tanked yeah
that would come home and I would tell
her like it ain't gonna work
and he ain't gonna do it and like the
night before the Showtime caving I did
it at Melrose
yeah brav and it was okay but not
something you want to [ __ ] film and
you're special
yeah and I came home and I go no it's
not gonna work and she goes [ __ ] you
you're doing it she goes you're afraid
of it because it's conceptually it's
it's out there yeah and you're you're
limping into it yeah you're limping into
that [ __ ] bit you're going to do it
it's going to kill but you just got to
let them know upfront whether you Cho
energy you gotta let them know this is
legit I stand by my [ __ ] work yeah
trust me
yeah and then the Showtime special I go
this is kind of a high concept but you
guys are really smart you'll totally get
this I have no irony
I just boom it's like 15 minutes long
yeah that's the bit Wow people are
always tweeting like I can't [ __ ]
believe you know down that irony should
know your wife writes your stuff well
like when does this happen and why I'm
sleeping now she's an insomniac and it
started when I was doing Gary I'm
married I was writing a book as well
right and
full stand up schedule and she said to
me I've been like an airplane and she
would be right now jokes and pets on the
road and people ask her like how do you
write so much she goes it was literally
just because my schedule was so crazy
right and she said well I can't be Gary
the show is called Gary unmarried uh-huh
um I can't be Gary right okay I can't go
out and be Jay Mohr on stage I can't
write this book about being on Saturday
Night Live yeah yeah so instead here how
come when women die they always say she
lit up a room yeah how come they always
say no one had anything bad to say about
her by my math if she got murdered there
was at least one guy yeah yeah I'm
rounding up but it's one yeah and he had
such bad things to say about her words
didn't work anymore point across he
needed tools the woods and time yeah
like that's and that's what I really
love about my wife's writing is she's so
much smarter than I am right like that
sentence I just said to you would never
cross my mind now when she words didn't
work to get his point across he needed
tools the woods and time yeah yes mark
that's like a lyric its Carlin esque
yeah now when she writes the stuff then
she gives it to you what on paper a
notebook and then you you start used to
start trying to do it at shows
immediately Wow next time on now at what
point do you stop writing like okay ever
no never
are you just adding to it it's like a
team I do anything I tag uh-huh like if
I write a lot of tags you got to
understand yeah I'm writing the tags but
I never would have been in the I would
never have gone down that street right -
you know but stuff tonight like the rock
and roll stuff yeah it's it's like I'm
kind of still peeling the onion on that
cuz I want to get that just right maybe
bang that out in a CD yeah I do rock and
roll stuff I don't get nominated for
Grammy let me yeah I really want to put
on a comedy album yeah it's being the
[ __ ] Grammy nominee list I just got
hired by the Grammys to to host
to do this show twice a month on Hulu or
their website or whatever on and I'll
have you on it but what we're gonna do
is talk about nominees and past wins of
comedy alternative rock and metal and
rock and roll
you know jethro tull investment abandon
yeah I know and that's the motel the
most obvious one you know but as I do
some research over the next couple weeks
I'll look at what else happened you know
what I mean of course I can't [ __ ] on
them instead about that kick you know
you can you talk about the curse of Best
New Artist wallet Jesus Jones Milli
Vanilli if your Best New Artist you're
out it has you know in movies you know
it the curse is what and introducing
you're out and introducing in the
credits oh yeah
if it says and introducing dean del rey
oh you're done really you gotta look
online of all and introducing uh-huh
crazy now it's a met you see old movies
oh yeah and introducing they don't use
that anymore do they
they still do they do and they're done
ah you're done help is did you be like
no well that's all negotiated yeah
single car don't know what that man yeah
yeah yeah Jerry Maguire my first movie
yep they're like the money's this yeah
which was nothing as I was a club comic
it yeah nothing to negotiate with yeah
like we're holding firm for single card
yeah that one um
don't hold [ __ ] cool yeah I know what it
meant yeah yeah oh yeah I'm like just
don't let it get away they're like oh no
but your first movie single card means
you're the only name on screen yeah
instead of Jay Mohr shirt and Jerry
O'Connell like two names right same time
right because now that you have single
card your first movie you're never going
shark art and if you do they're gonna
give you a little extra money yeah for
the shared car yeah that's hilarious all
this effect where you want [ __ ] right
and so and is okay yeah isn't it weird
though they said we're start with I want
check it out
yeah introducing I'm gonna look dawn I
mean never not even like elements like
they're gone I'm gonna Google it you
should
man so that's like Best New Artist for
the biz is so weird right that you're
talking about that it's like you know
better no but I mean it's so creepy
kooky like if you don't really oke
altogether if you don't go to school for
acting and you don't you know study it
and stuff and I'll said you're like a
comedian they go we got a role and they
give it to it's amazing how you can
float around on the set and have no idea
what's going on but then when you go up
and step up to the camera you go over
these guys is just doing the same [ __ ]
you know to me but all the eggs leave ya
it's make-believe let's do it for free
all the weird [ __ ] like that when the
guy comes up because all right we're
gonna shoot dirty over your shoulder and
you just act like you know what they're
mainly oh yeah yeah shooting dirty and
then they guess what are you doing I
just told you we're shooting dirty
already showed it you know I always said
what I don't know what that means
oh you didn't boys really always Wow and
they go oh I'm sorry means I'm gonna I
mean I'm a little piece of your shoulder
in the shot yeah no okay
oh wow that never for I never fronted
that's genius
oh and in real life if you like say a
word yeah that I don't understand I go
and I'll do interviews on the radio show
jammer sports and some guys go like
something so I go I don't know what that
word means
yeah yeah right that's the only way you
learn it's been my biggest ally honesty
that's the only way you learn right yeah
because stage being honest on stage like
how you are yeah like like we said in
the beginning 80% of your act any comic
listening 80% of your act is already
happened to you so you just got to get
to that place like usually right before
you're falling asleep keep a notebook by
your bed yeah you think of some weird
[ __ ] your grandfather said
yep just [ __ ] write it down it's true
and soon I tell you what this [ __ ] is
coming when I do the coke off the dick
joke that's real story I was at the
store and I was looking at my notes
getting ready to go on these two guys
are just drunk [ __ ] talking too loud
right by the bathroom you know just like
you know dudes in the hall and and I
hear the guy tell me oh yeah yeah
just snort alleline a coke off my dick
dude and then they high-fived right and
I just thought like you know how long
I've heard this story in my life you
know how much coke I've done you know
you know I mean it's impossible yeah not
a good surface for cocaine yeah and then
I break it round they don't want to give
the bit away because it's it's brand new
no because it's brand new and it's it's
it but I break it down and and and and
and as soon as they said that I walk
they introduced me at the store I walked
on and I just started telling the story
and it crushed and then I just tweaked
it a little bit and now it's good you're
not ever finished never funny I could
told me peel the onion oh yeah
no near jokes are over done with well
tonight I came up with something as soon
as I walked offstage and went oh and and
wrote it down right away for the joke it
just came to me as I was walking off as
you said hey good job and I I went oh
[ __ ] oh and I just pulled into the room
real quick and wrote it down but I
always say that frat guys always say
like yeah Dawg I was laying pipe boy and
some pipe last night frat guys you know
I was laying pipe and I think well first
of all you can't [ __ ] chop up coke on
a pipe dick it's like it's round it's
not gonna sit on it out of it so that
came to me right away I'm gonna [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of her yeah [ __ ] saw ya [ __ ]
her pants there's all these things that
kind of [ __ ] her so bad yeah I'm a
[ __ ] so bet your [ __ ] job yeah
I'm losing my voice I got cuts get out
and let's go sing some rock yeah man
Dean Del Rio going downstairs yeah we're
gonna sing her the name of the band this
cover band metal shop or you could say
the name of the band your podcast
oh you can't oh yeah I was like don't
say the name of the van Oh their cover
man you can say the name right you know
it wasn't for legal reasons
Oh [ __ ] be a horn of it only Dean and
jayjay time oh I don't want these guys
on my podcast appearance thanks man
let's have fun tomorrow night I love you
there is J more guys thank you or guys
thank you
or guys thank you or guys thank you or
guys thank you or guys thank you
or guys thank you
guys thank you poor guys thank you poor
guys thank you
poor guys thank you poor guys thank you